what is up everybody happy right he's so
good to see you beautiful people you
know what time it is we're gonna be
talking about the Spotify logo redesign
it some of you guys were wondering why
would they touch the spot of our logo
there's nothing wrong with it or is
there no Everton it has bravely stepped
up to take on this monumental challenge
here so let's get into it you know what
we're gonna do we're gonna talk about
the logos you love and sometimes the
logos that you love to hate and this may
not be one that you love to hate we're
gonna get into the redesign and today
after a little bit of delay is joining
me once again is Everton our gionee yeah
and you guys can follow him on instagram
at Everton guard gionee he's from Brazil
and at the bottom there you can go to
his website if you like his work if
you'd like his thinking his style his
aesthetic and generally his tattoos and
you think he's a cool guy
go check them out on the website it's
Everton guard Janee comm dot ER go check
him out and why cuz this is gonna be you
this is his work this is the body of his
work and it's really good he actually
helped me design something that I'm
gonna share with you at a different
point in time but we're here not to talk
about him or me we're here to talk about
this we're gonna redesign this Spotify
logo to something else and I don't know
maybe I was talking to my friend Brian
Collins yesterday and he's asking why
Everton why would you do this so here we
go I'm gonna cut to this other screen
here I went to the Colin site and you
guys know Colin's they do amazing
beautiful work for really ginormous
brands like Spotify like twitch and so
many others Equinox hotels okay and we
step into this for like oh there's a
dangerous territory man because this is
some beautiful work beautiful color
palettes just this complete identity
system that he's developed so these are
mixed shoes to fill now some of you were
going to instantly hate what it is we're
going to do so I want to set the tone
and intention for what we're trying to
do today what we want to do what we want
to do you guys and pay attention to this
is to explore what else it could be this
is the the alternate dimension the
multiple earths if you will from the DC
in the Marvel Universe so just chill out
relax
let's look at what we can do with this
and see where else we can take it that
way we know if we love the original or
oh if we love the new logo okay so
without further ado every time I'm gonna
stop sharing so you can share what
you're doing how you doing buddy hey all
right Chris all right how are everybody
nervous here yes yes for sure and you
have to show the Brian Collins okay good
all right jump in let's get to it and
I'll be monitoring your comments guys if
you leave your thoughtful comments and
questions thoughtful thoughtful is the
key word here I will be sure to try to
answer them during the show all right
let's get to it
yeah screen is shared already now yep go
for it not yet
okay are you sharing it sure it now
let's go he's trying to build the
suspense take it easy guys is just an
exercise here girl just let goes nobody
was hurt no kittens are killed no it's
just the largest music streaming but
whatever so a little bit of history
first let's start slowly here it was
what if I was falling in 2006 it as I
said is the word world's largest music
streaming service today they offer
access access on-demand to over 15
million songs from you know the the
major label Sony EMI Warner Universal
but the app was launched in 2008 and
from there to now they have 286 monthly
active users man Wow I'm one of them
yeah I'm one of them
I'm one of them too so you know let's
take it from there this is what the
original drum
in 2008 and one thing we can be glad
here is that when we were we are
starting you know that's something that
we always can improve later so I don't
know much of you guys but this for me
it's so 2008 like you know there's
strokes and it was the first time that
the three striped the Wi-Fi signal the
streaming signal was presented and
that's a huge part of the the logo till
now yeah the original is not a good logo
oh the the guy who did the who created
that it was Christian Wilson I believe
is from Sweden where the the company was
born and you know that sound wave that
streaming it kind of associate leaders
in association of the company does it
take with technology and music
connection so it was the first one very
interesting very playful too a lot of
people complaining about this screen
nowadays it's just more bright right
more more joyful more young and you know
for a company like that the screen was
off so they fix it later the next one
was an update in 2013 the same guy
Christian and this other one andreas
Holmstrom they got rid of the jumpy no
they changed the word mark and for me
it's just a right move in the right
direction to to be the massive company
that they they are right this one is too
playful was the beginning right yeah
this one's a little better although for
me answering the question why changing
this and we're gonna try yeah
I mean it it always bugged me the way
that the Wi-Fi is aligned in the in the
circle it's more to the left side it's
not it's optically aligned but at the
same time technically for my tastes like
I just want things to be more more
attached to to a point to you know that
and that's why Spotify it's gotten the
word mark nothing wrong with that it's
okay and from this point they were like
huge already and for those who might
wondering oh did you fix it did you give
it a try to fix the Wi-Fi single so I
did and that's the results for is I play
some grades here some lines - you
understand - help me understand where is
it on the circle and it's rotated it's
out of Center it and I don't know I
tried to do my own version of that just
to get my conscious like fear you know
you mean yeah we draw it just just and
kind of to understand
what am I facing you know like the
monster I'm fighting so just to be
friends with it so I tried a version
last rounded you know because for me
that thing here is it's too rounded and
you know it's just different from from
the world Mar it's okay
so I went and did this you know fix the
thing I don't know what you guys think
on the chat so it's don't worry they're
supporting you don't worry
yeah nice nice like yeah yeah yeah
all right so okay so I couldn't come
here and do just this to this logo right
it's just like be an update for them
like just but the thing is is that the
creators they want it to be something
very very fun very personal and I read
an interview from them they're talking
about something that they tried goto
ratio and dry grid - to align the thing
and it's just not work for them for
their vision so everyone has one right
yeah yeah yeah yeah so this one here
at this point they were pretty solid in
advertising and there you have some
consistency through the brand or black
or green you know both typography and
it's all there so they did an amazing
job here you know with the consistency
and all of that but it was in a point
that it was tucked in like a provider of
streaming service only and Spotify was
growing to be bigger than that
so they I I mean I assume right didn't
talk to anyone there but I certain want
to move a step further
maybe individuals and just try to be
less like a service only and to be like
a culture like people having experiences
with the brand and all of that
so then callings happen and for from my
opinion it was a game changer right they
did an amazing job and for me to please
a huge number of people imagine millions
and millions of users and have that
power to to please the majority it's
something that you know you can you
should take your head off too
there and they did an amazing job so I
did him chill out guys I didn't want to
massive callings and and you know the
big big ones
hey I'm not crazy like that but uh I did
though explore a little further of my
mark that I did and try to you know see
if I could match the style and if that
could be something that works as well so
Colleen's said this and I quote what if
I confronted the same realization every
fast-growing tech company does a great
product wins early adopters but a great
brain wins the mainstream and that's a
great thing a great thought so and
they're big players right
they're there for the masses and that's
amazing but you have to every my nose
that's ballsy here's something like that
the solution they find it it's in the
solution they find said I mean shift the
perception of Spotify was just a tech
company you know that they're just only
providing streaming services and all
this all those stuff so they went
through that motive when an individual
and I quote again from their side when
an individual makes a personal
connection in the Thome a song they
their reaction is to cry cheer scream
sing jump
whatever get chills or as they phrase it
worse with emotion so that first word
it's just the motive that they could
graphically translate and that's a
that's a great move you know we all are
familiar with the dough tone photography
which was a great move a great solution
to a problem a big problem Spotify was
getting
photos from every artist and you can
imagine different angles different
visions different captures lightning and
all this stuff and so the way that they
find to to maintain some certain of
identity was to do with the dual tone
and it was a success right
huge the sex yes so yeah so this is
callings their work and we can see the
difference here from the previous black
and green from 2013 now they are like
they're are being merged with the
culture with the Millennials and and all
of that you know when I when you saw
something like that bold brave young
joyful is just it translate well with
that phrase the burst of emotion which
for me music is I I can't think of a
that I'm not with my Spotify on you know
so this is a great thing a great move
from from from from callings and hats
off to them so what I tried to do and
hotel guys I will show up a logo process
right and I feel but I tried to kind of
conveyed the idea that this Spotify is a
tech company you know they are rooted on
this but at the same time I wanted to
explore what callings did and to merged
with their their visual identity I make
myself clear right now so yeah
everyone's following up how good yep
so yeah I I was exploring things like
connection of exploring things like tech
vibe
you know like I wanted to do something
that has layers depth
you know Spotify is just uh you can
scroll and watch your favorite artists
and you are always passing and there's
always someone on the line and I was
making that analogy I would say and so I
went there and tried to do something
that just for fun or for exercise or for
us to discuss you know I'm not saying
that I would present this to Spotify or
a my logo is just better you know I made
something amazing and you know but yeah
I did a bunch of things and I I thought
about something that could be really
interesting and it's a marketing thing
right now so I was thinking about if the
the shed or the audience could go to my
Instagram it maybe follow me there I can
do some stories revealing the other you
know the other chances that I took and
create like a list of friends there just
for the new ones that are coming that
would be something something nice too
so I did that grid system here I was
convinced that this mark could be a good
a good outcome so I'm sure that I'm
showing the logo process here
it's not Ronnie nope
looks like hung up on something they're
doing it now can I interrupt the share
and sure again yeah Ark please yeah just
might be sharing different window yeah
yeah yeah okay I hang tight guys we're
gonna get this in one second I'm gonna
go and use this time to read a few
comments while you test that out okay
there's a lot of people who are saying
like hang tight everybody it's important
to kind of hear the rationale and the
research and this is the important part
of the logo design creation process I'm
not just making shapes on a grid it
looks like we're up and running now yeah
yeah it's all good
okay let's go real quick is it doing
something yeah I didn't know no it's not
doing anything
it's night day nothing looks like it's
still frozen it wasn't why timeline is
moving but we're not seeing anything
happen on the screen you guys are the
future team you have the video right
yeah I'm gonna pull it up real quick
pull it up as a back up here while we're
doing this I wonder what's going on here
it was working that or before you should
you shared it I think cuz I saw it move
maybe did you quit quick time maybe just
quit and reopen it okay yeah okay let me
see if I can read some of the comments
here people are saying already they see
the third concept the piano that's kind
of cool people are saying they see the
Death Star I guess they're happy to see
the Death Star right yeah yeah it's part
of the the pop culture too right so I
think that it's the target but I dunno I
could give it a shot John I haven't
voted okay yeah that'll work
okay so mark you share it and then
everton you can just talk about it okay
is there any sound on the file is just
mistress video right oh just no sound
okay here we go so if you need me to
pause let me know
on the plate no it is a really quick
video by that time I already know what
should i I do
so this part is just and it's important
for me to build something and know how
to rebuild it later
you know sometimes we're in a hurry
you're doing things you're exploring
shapes your whatever and all the
suddenly you don't remember the steps
that you take to to build that and so
for me it's important to have awareness
from the by step that I did to achieve
the result so I started dividing I
square in third parts and everything
counts me like I divided that in three
and then I can use this I can divide the
the every layout and play some some
random elements to do the except exactly
same idea from the logo and that keep
consistency with everything that that is
it's made that make sense yes so I
divided in third part and then I divided
that first column the the bold stripes
in six and then I found the the gaps
that I wanted to use you know placed
there divided by three right now
hey everything how would you describe
what this symbol means I'm like I think
the nerd in me is thinking it's like
like a computer like yeah sign or
something yeah it's just something that
when yeah I usually working with
keywords so I was thinking about data I
was thinking about you know plugs and
things related to music as well I was
thinking about those things and I think
unconsciously those things ended up
emerged right eventually I guess but the
thing with the piano or the acoustic
guitar the strings was not on purpose
was more thinking about something
technological if it is if it's more less
digital you know that could remind
something like from the 70s like a
vintage thing because I I drink a lot
from that from there that phase of
design so here's a quick gift that I did
you know just what thing I did with the
the the the the symbol and the word
marked the word mark I just slightly
modify it you know the Spotify original
they rounded the corners you know and in
my version that that was off so I have
some really sharp II edges and so I
removed that and the dot of the eye I
maintained that square also
I can stop the video and I moved to the
brand identity right now
so the way that I translate that into a
visual language you know kind of the
colonies did but I didn't want to cut
their style except I do except I did I
did the color palette I didn't mess with
that you know so I have to know play
around with it see what people think
and let's have a good Friday yeah yeah I
want to share my screen again desktop
sure right so it's all cool so from
there I was thinking about something
really that could be dissect into parts
you know we can play around with the
stripes is this something that that that
this concept in yellow that I like that
is further and you know its proximity
and you know whatever I don't know how
to say that in English but you have that
kind of you know in and out kind of
thing instantly I think about some
animation you know stripes coming and
going in those movement which which
Millennials are you know they're ready
to go they wake up they wake up noon but
they're ready to go for the rest of the
day right kind of that so you know
playing around with some photography
lates inside behind and in front of kind
of that thing I didn't want mess with
the the the green and black thing here
just not to completely drive people
a wrong idea it's still with Spotify but
it's different but it's the same you
know yeah
so here the better at the color palette
that that that callings did which it has
no mistake man you can throw whatever
color day they chose there it's gonna
look good so I did that with the
Spotfire new kind of version six hundred
people like wow you made some new
friends and you may have lots of you but
who knows yeah yeah but that's part of
the game so yeah so here I was exploring
that idea
this part here on the green is that I
divided in three parts you know there's
the logo here on in tomato on the left
so you can make those decisions based on
you know the process the whole process
and we can share that into visual
language to you know try to do the same
the same foam that they use which is
circular and play some color background
really modern kind of design and one
thing that I forgot to mention I guess
is that their target with Instagram and
and all that new social kind of thing
it's just true visual right it's visual
and so you have to to look good on that
on the screen
and so here a couple of things that I
did trying to explore this concept of
girls you know those thing that you were
passing artists you know there's one in
behind and then it's the upfront right
now the hot hot spot of the moment
whatever and then next month it's so
quickly so it has that dynamic things
moving around even though I did I didn't
did any animation because um I'm just
I'm illustrator a guy so black and in
green for the nostalgic people that
might Wow why did you change that wears
green wears black so you know Dan I just
I just noticed side the word mark here
is the wrong one sorry the mask guys
don't worry well yeah it's supposed to
be the square one yeah the square one
Dan just here two men but here's the the
the after him before thing I just had to
change that burn mark it's this this one
here should be there and you know that's
it's not okay so we should we talk about
it then yeah yeah for sure for sure
hey oh now the audience is gonna come to
life in a second here so are they alive
yeah it's like first I have to say this
like oh alright hopefully John got that
cut alright I'm introducing side
graphics here so the audience is it's
just wide range of reactions from and I
like it I'll get it alright it's growing
on me and I like it
but there's a lot of questions about the
connections of the things that people
associate with the symbol itself people
are saying it feels electronic digital
fingers laced together it feels it's
it's reminiscent of an old 18 T logo
some people are saying
very digital in terms of its vibe so
there's a lot of questions going on here
okay
now I'm not gonna weigh in my opinion
just yet I'm gonna yeah yeah I think
that I mean I get it
all of their I have that that that same
thinking it's just a process it's not
that it should stop there and not finish
with it probably if I would it was a
real thing I would spend a whole lot of
you know checking those those alert
signs yeah I'm trying to do you know so
I had this let's explore this a little
further so let's get back and and it's a
process and for me it's like this is the
fun of it you know and it's it's alright
for you to to not be able to to get at
first time or you know you just don't
give up leave it to rest a little bit
and then back to it share with friends
I did that with some of mine and really
their problem their problem
damn that's saying that I'm [ __ ] so
because I heard it before jump in here I
know when you work you do a lot of
exploration yeah this logo process I saw
the research the thinking and then I
just saw the finished thing do you
happen to have all the different symbols
you've explored a handi that we can look
at or no yeah can I see them please okay
let's do that because I know often times
we can react to the finished product but
I think what's a bigger learning
opportunity is to see all the things he
explored sometimes and it's often the
case when I look at designers work when
they breadcrumb all the explorations I
go back and say that versions really
interesting and why am I even bringing
this up because when you're working on
the project you lose
is objectivity you just don't know
anymore you just keep doing it and
eventually times up it's do and that's
what you created so sometimes it helps
if we were actually working and designs
to do with many people to kind of put up
against the wall and say everybody
what's your take what's your opinion and
then from that reaction and that
brainstorming process something new
something that's collaborative that can
be built up from a variety of points of
view and so this is kind of an
interesting moment for us to kind of see
what else you've done and allow me to
kind of just comment on it along with
our audience that are tuning in all 600
people six hundred plus so let's take a
look at it six other friends yeah six
hundred friends six under your friends
are tuned in today yeah okay just a
minute okay you having some computer
issues yeah yeah so I ran if you resell
computers Everton could use a new
computer let us know Chad if you'd like
to send a computer to him and we'll be
sure to thank you for it he's running on
an iMac that's circa 2000 15 mm yeah
yeah boy it's taken a long time to open
up it must be a massive file a lot of
explorations yeah okay let's see if we
have a comment or a question that we can
address our case you see anything I know
there's a lot of opinions going on but I
didn't see anything with a question mark
do it not yeah not a whole lot of
questions but some people are just
wondering quite a spot if I get to
implement this again if this is your
first time tuning into these little gory
news these are educational projects so
we're trying to show you the process and
go through the mindset of the designer
as they're working through these you
know decisions hey you have at least one
friend from India a budding learner is
saying I'm one friend from India and
people are encouraging others to go
check out his work on Instagram which is
at Everton guard gionee you guys go
check it out
he does some beautiful work we don't my
friend we just grabbed Randall's off the
street and say yo come on our show and
design a logo with us legit people
that's who we want on our show all right
oh just a heads up if you guys are
interested in participating we're gonna
send out a link so you guys can submit
to be a potential designer on the show
so look out for that we'll post it on
Instagram in our other social media
yeah I've did post on this on Twitter
and Facebook but not a ton of people
responded so you see it's like it's easy
it's brave of you to talk from the back
gallery or the back way way way in the
back all you people are super brave but
come on the show and join us and show us
what you can do different story so I
applaud no matter if I like it or if I
dislike it everybody steps up who puts
himself in the spotlight to be judged
and critiqued by thousands of anonymous
people and 600 friends everything is it
up yet or do we give up on this no no
it's it's up yeah let's do it I'm trying
to get back to zoom to share my screen
looks like he's frozen
is he frozen did we lose them are you
still there everything yeah I'm here I'm
listening
your videos frozen oh yeah my okay there
we go you're back all right
so here this there are a couple of
explorations I did just doing that up
yet give us a sec there we go all right
whoo all right now I just want to say
this because I think this person is
gonna keep typing this in Madden wants
me to explain the future having a logo
process and he's saying please with a
lot of Z's in it we'll deal with that
later
okay yes we'll deal with it so let's get
back into this thing
so what are we looking at here yes we're
looking at some explorations I did I
work I tried at first to do something
because of the simplicity of the you
know the brand of equity and all of that
with the stripes but I ended up like
losing you're losing oh love it that
people love I guess and it's just too
right I did some s explorations here in
there trying to again do that that
duplicating things you know here's the
same thing with the pattern like some
vinyl kind of thing you know so the
music was he wasn't there - he's an
other version of the logo I presented
with less stripes on it thinking about
connection with people I drew this
locker here - you know - just I separate
this but the file is is even more beer
than it is but just once I I concentrate
and I send to mark for run an update so
they were the rest of it is just nothing
really to - okay just a little bit then
okay so I happened to be in the room
when Brian Collins was sharing the story
of Spotify and how they arrived at what
they did
now you notice couple of things from the
the logo that was created original
to the reduce circle Collins didn't do
that much to the mark when they took on
the rebranding project what they did was
they created a whole ecosystem for this
to live in be the color palettes and
maybe what I need to do is share that
screen so give me one second should I
stop mine yeah stop yours okay you don't
have to but I needed to switch my
monitor settings here all right yeah I
kind of dude are can you do the talking
in here so I can work on this yeah well
I wanted to address something I came up
here in the chat so somebody was asking
let's see
before we move from the concept process
to the development process should we get
a second third fourth opinion or should
we just trust our gut and move forward
yeah what was your kind of approach to
this yeah my purchased
I got a trust what I believe you know
what I do take others opinions seriously
and consider them you know but at the
end of the day man know no one is gonna
support you you know like you've got a
step front from it you know you gotta do
it your best and believe on it and you
know even if it is not your best and be
humble too
you know that's not it's not my best
maybe you know three two years from now
I'll take it over again and that's okay
it's a process the learning process but
trust our gut always and I think that's
speaks the importance of what I hear you
know Chris talked about a lot when
working with their clients and making
sure that you're checking in with them
frequently rather than just having the
big reveal at the end where they're
surprised and you don't know if they're
gonna like it or not yeah so there's a
there's a shift here in my thinking on
this because when I was in school we
weren't really taught how to work with
clients we're just taught to be great
for makers to try to communicate a
concept but it was missing a vital
component the vital component is there's
somebody else who has to live with this
system that you've built
and I hate to say this but they have as
much say if not more say than you even
though they hired you and so we have to
get off our pedestal and think that they
came to me the design God and this is
what I'm gonna give them and they should
be so lucky I think there was an error
when that happened with people like Saul
Bass and Paul ran but that's many
decades ago we don't live in that space
anymore we want to be collaborative
because it's like somebody designing
furniture for you and then they drop it
off and you get to live with it and they
walk away and they sell another piece of
furniture to somebody else and so you
want to make sure it fits you it feels
right and it's usable so I'm gonna
switch over to my monitor here I'm going
to show you the Spotify system and I
think we have to think about this in a
system so the original logo that Brian
Collins and his team did it refines some
things and it kept some of the character
and in that presentation in which he was
talking to to us sharing the story he
said that the key insight was that these
technologists were music lovers first
and they came up with really smart
technology on how to share their passion
and love for music so that one song
would lead you to another song and it
was kind of figuring you out and so I
think it's important to keep some of
that so the original logo is feels like
sound waves like a volume or a speaker
and it's coming out and there's energy
to it and it expands it gets bigger and
it's pretty cool I didn't see it so much
as a Wi-Fi signal but also because it's
a streaming service there's a second
layered meeting in there but it's round
it's fun it's friendly and I think from
a business point of view we don't want
to focus on the technology we want to
focus on the benefits of it and the
genius comes in in taking the visual
language which all of us could sit there
and say I could have done that yeah but
you didn't and you didn't do it for a
company of this size and this way to
make everything cohesive these artists
by treating everything in a duotone
fashion with the colors that they have
they unify everything and it basically
you can take any asset do that and this
shows you the strength of the system and
Spotify more than anything else for
from a design point of view is about a
system so having these dynamic lines it
feel like lightning or fire or spark a
burst of energy it has a very lyrical
quality to it it explodes with energy
and that's really good
these dots create depth there's a lot of
movement and dynamism to it so it's
really nice that image with Pharrell and
then again the duotone it's working you
can see it and they're just showing you
so many different ways of integrating
typography and the logo so in an
instance like this where your logo is
very simple and it has you haven't done
a whole lot of tweaking to it from a
client point of view it's important for
you to present the system the ecosystem
and then they start to fall in love with
it so at the beginning when you see a
market even with Everton smark whether
you like it or hate it your first
reaction is it's new it's different I
don't like it over time through repeated
exposure you may learn to love it or you
may not and that's okay and Michael
Beirut we're gonna talk about this every
single time he says people often mistake
and they think that it's a diving
competition the logo comes in and we
judge it on the splash that it makes on
the initial dive he's like it's not like
that it's more like a swimming race if
anything else it's a marathon and over
time the feelings that we have about the
product to service the people the
culture the company become associated
with this abstract symbol so if they do
a bad job it doesn't really matter how
good this little mark is so that we
learn to love it over time but we want
to make sure that the mark is on
strategy now you can see that those few
elements the kind of jagged mountain
peaks or these sparks or abstract
representation of fire or use the
different scaled dots move so there's
something really cool there and now
they're introducing patterns into the
background with is more organic shape
also very cool and then I think this is
the last image here now there's still a
couple more so it's a system and so
think about an identity design as a
system design and what really got me
excited about what Everton was doing is
that when he started to use the shapes
these piano keys or these chipboard
kinds of shapes when you use them as
windows into the images it started to
come alive and I saw that you guys were
commenting on that when you started to
see that you were like oh that's
interesting I kind of like that now so
that's that's just like if I can give
you one tip all you aspiring logo
identity designers branders out there
think of the mark is just one small part
of a larger ecosystem and you kind of
have to see and it's the totality to see
how they work with each other how they
complement one another and then you
start to get a feel for it okay so I'm
gonna go back to my deck here
because I want to ask you guys in the
comments and I think I know what you're
gonna say but let's see what happens
here
a bracelet brace for impact
there's the original on the left and the
revised version on the right what do you
guys think do you prefer the original or
the revised that's all we want to know
A or B Collins there it is all right so
all right I'm gonna stop here guys go
ahead and I'll give you second to
comment we'll see what they're saying
and we could read what six hundred
friends are about to say on the internet
should bring Collins on right now you
know original a Collins A or B Everton
or revised that's it
original or revised okay and I think
here everything I know that I've seen
the body of your work it has a very
retro feel to it I think that's one of
your constraints it has a 70s 80s vibe
to it I think that's really cool and I
would encourage you to continue to
develop that vibe and that aesthetic oh
here the votes come in it's a little
bananas yeah it's a song for ABBA
Appa yeah so okay before we wrap up the
show I want to say a couple of things as
you guys are weighing in first make sure
you guys follow Everton I'll show his
information in a second here and you
guys can check him up and the other
thing I want to say is this in
next episodes of logo redesign when you
choose a local to redo pick something
that you think is universally hated now
Everton decided for his first mountain
to climb he's gonna straight go straight
for Mount Everest he did he wasn't
beating around the bush there was no
learning peak and so we encouraged
people to do that because you have to
risk a lot if you want to win big it's
just the way it goes so for me I think
his latest mark so I appreciate the
exploration it feels a little off it
feels almost too old it feels a little
too stiff and a little too digital for
my taste
but I do appreciate 100% I think he did
a wonderful job in exploring this and I
think if he had spent a little bit more
time integrating all the elements and
the shapes into things I think more of
you would be inclined to give it a shot
okay or give it a chance and that's not
about that nice don't be crazy
yeah go ahead every time go ahead no I
just want to thank you for the words and
I agree with you man
there's a quote here that that I write
on my notebook here take the risk or
lose the chance no I love that about
that right yeah take the risk or losing
champions yeah with the risk and he
didn't lose the chance I love but I'm
gonna I'm gonna rise everybody pick a
logo that you should think is but don't
pick a logo that is from the
world-renowned much-beloved firm love
firm just stay away from those ones okay
go with a junky firm you never heard of
some of these uncles cousins brothers
neighbor designed go with those logos
and I hope you enjoyed this series guys
don't forget to give it a like comment
and subscribe our guest today has been
Everton guard Joanie I'm sure I'm not
saying his name right but go follow him
today go check out his work and you'll
see like the amazing work that he does
at Everton guard Joanie and Instagram
and check out his website and on behalf
of the entire team you guys I hope you
have a great Friday than a weekend and
I'll see you guys next week with
whatever program we have so there's the
graphic Joan is gonna play the music
boom don't forget to hit that Bell for
notifications and thank you all for
being part of the one-billion mission to
teach be
well how to make a living doing what
they love that's it for us and if you
feel so inclined drop us a little
something I'm at the Christo and that's
it for me